yeah welcome to this video playing save
our bear 12 ok maybe Kings Indian set up
you know ok five ok what what do I play
let's play five it's not clear ok it
stays within the area of the English
opening yeah here I actually have a
setup that I I 545 ok let's flick in a 5
to get rid of the day poem this kind of
setup I I played back when I was still
employing the Kings in yet on a regular
basis and I always thought that black
should have fun quite quite decent
position you cannot be in in bad shape
if you have a five and d5 in the center
I mean ok you can be in bad shape but
it's it doesn't happen too often I'm
brought upon centers normally worth
something ok knight c6 he will probably
play Knight to g5 so maybe 927 this
better maybe ok Oh interesting hmm
okay so it's really Russian Alice if I
go if all then both my bishops are not
not too great okay but what about maybe
something like should a five an idea his
rook needs to go on a very unnatural
scram in this case now let's play this I
want to want to play them with more
active pieces here he goes rugby to our
players something like Whoopi aid unjust
them just play on the piece activity if
he takes I can't take 25 but I don't
think that this is any good really I
take before at the end and I'm very
active I don't don't think this should
be oh it's just playing it okay mmm now
I didn't think this was on there's also
this idea might be 64 yeah this looks
very good actually yes there's some big
idea no don't think someone thinks it's
just good for me he can go a forward and
take I take me to with with the tempo
and where is this work going I can also
just take deform this is actually a
question an open question if I should
just take the form this threatens on d3
but no but Bishop f4 okay let's play
this first here he doesn't have a great
response on that anyway
maybeee form may be formed but I think I
can take n play Bishop g4 vortex be to
be sure Peter Bishop g4 fringy for rugby
30 p.m. okay so now the slightest is
really a man in stable peace should I am
attack it may be first with the move
like a queen bee 6i might go if I'd on
that but if i take defaults got Bishop
f4 which is a bit bit inconvenient look
be fine for something hmm ok I need to
need to move I mean I'm in good shape
here the only question was some was
there something better Bishop f4 looks
very natural no I'm threatening will be
6 also asking where this night is going
we should therefore looks like the the
normal move I'm not quite sure why he is
some what he is thinking about yeah he
did this at that is there some special
trick or something why you thought so
long and another question where to go if
i advanced you can even go ok well maybe
maybe just here we should be seven a
very greedy move very very greedy
okay yeah and I sacrificed an exchange
didn't really am appreciate that before
oh he can take and play group aah this
is embarrassing oh it's an increase my
concentration here it looks like okay
didn't play okayed it looked it looked
rather rather tricky to say the least
Kim activate this I mean the only good
thing about this is that I'm still I'm
still having really active pieces and
it's not not so clear how white should
proceed he can play rook e8
maybe this one keeping the pressure on
e2
yeah of course I'm much worse with the
exchange down Oh mr. Channing one I see
turning this form for just a pawn you
probably need to take it okay but I
probably cannot take cannot take me to
am this is so why actually why can I not
take it
I'm on b5 some protecting this actually
it's not really a pin I mean
meaning I had threatened bishop f three
years oh and he cannot adult see how he
improves this maybe you can play just
Bishop g2 the sir or this one
just ya got g4 at the end time morning
ah 11 seconds crap 11 seconds
and there's really nothing going on
check
check check check yeah it's just just a
ton of Austin's position is nothing for
what time yeah it's nothing just just
nothing going on just a draw yeah I I
spent far too much too much time at one
point where I may be played here after
Bishop t5 i spent like 20 seconds for
for not much and now of course there
this rook takes d4 is just nonsense I
mean he said his Knicks changeup and
this just gives back all the material
for for no reason and then yeah but I
was our I spent too much time losing on
time at the end yeah i think i had a
this was certainly a good foot black
night a four winds great good to good to
learn that at a for now yeah nitey for
as much better if you consider this yes
somehow you want to go towards the
center but if this is this is really
easy to see and fur go here he cannot
protect this because this is not on so
he would need to go here and after this
it's curtains get this was stupid I knew
that this was it was bad but um I didn't
really am calculate just played nazi
form alright thanks for watching